[Musique]
que de pouvoir je vais même vous touchez
un coffre senti j'aimerais parler de
l'homme ces créatures merveilleuses qui
est un être spirituel ayant une âme
lucien des émotions de la sensation mais
n' ya quand même une enveloppe de
poussier ap les corps qui nous permet
d'interagir avec la société et aussi
avec le site héritier mais je voudrais
vous dire ce tome 7 créatures
merveilleuses ce qu'on pouvait dire il
ya des valeurs perdant oui l'homme et
l'accueil est une merveilleuse et
hésitèrent en plus de talent de
potentialités mais j'ai découvert
également que le monde dans lequel nous
sommes aujourd'hui est un monde
totalement détruit par qui a les hommes
parce que aujourd'hui l'homme est en
train de détruire ce que la nature nous
a donné la nati s'est détruit
aujourd'hui les grands si nice ou parler
comment faire pour créer un monde
meilleur
oui les nations se détruisent le monde
s'est détruit et les hommes s'apprécient
choc face à tout ceci
nous vivons dans un environnement
totalement les face aux crises et des
blagues chaque jour
et quand je regarde autour de moi je
vois mes frères mes soeurs qui souffre
et qui cherchent un idéal il veut
quelque chose de très chers qu'ils ont
perdu
c'est quoi je parle de la richesse de la
faire
la greffe est aujourd'hui j'ai regardé
autour de moi j'ai cru que la paix était
blanc semaine et baros j'ai cru qu'on
était loi mais n'était pas noir
j'ai cru qu'elle était jeune mélanie
jaune ni blanche ni noire mais elle est
comment quelques a dit mais j'ai
vraiment apprécié sa parole que la paix
est encore hautement et non un vain mot
mais quel comportement pour développer
ce secteur pour que la lp que nous
recherchions l'eau puisque nous nous qui
seul à trouver un comportement quelques
battements pour a pu développer
vous l'avez fait réunis autour de nous
tout le monde est la recherche de la
paix les éditions pour la paix existe
partout mais la bp n'est pas trouvée
ehrlich à à ceux là je me suis dit même
si la retrouvons est ce que nous
pourrons la garde et la cultiver
une chose est de trouver le jeu et de
garder une chose est de fait peser cette
paix je voudrais nous dit retour de nom
aujourd'hui il ya des situations
dégradantes
il ya des guerres pas si des guépards là
nous avons aujourd'hui des enfants sans
parents parce que les parents sont morts
après des guerres et enfants ça père
devient maintenant un enfant sans le
père est un enfant ça le père qui n'a
pas recommandé un fait voilà pourquoi je
crois si nous pouvons éviter ce
gaspillage humain nous pourrons avoir
des enfants qui sont élevés dans une
bonne maison dans un bon foyer
oui en réussissant je me suis dit si
nombreux projets la paix dans le monde
et pour des clowns retour en écho à la
base à quoi le foyer aujourd'hui le
foyer
décousu nous avons aujourd'hui dans les
foyers des femmes avec enfants mais
l'épée sont où ils sont ailleurs et je
prie si la conscience alors humaines
pour être touché si l on pourrait
toucher et savoir qu'ils ont leur place
la loi dans le foyer et prendre soin des
enfants
je pense que les enfants vont maintenant
donner ce qu'ils ont déchets oui alami à
l'école et ainsi la paix sera dans les
écoles et si la piste dans les écoles
les étudiants pourront aussi aide non
des instruments utilisés mais le tour de
la société mais selon alors des agences
de paix et vont répondre la fin un peu
partout oui nous sommes ceux qui ont
détruit la nature
ceux qui détruisent encore le monde
aujourd'hui à cause des intérêts mais
nous sommes aussi cela qui courent à
l'approché de la paix
aujourd'hui les autres ou calmement
ville sur la tête de mes difficiles et
d'autres rêvent maintenant est d'aller
vie dans la ville ou dans d'autres
planètes
je ne sais si cela de créer ou api des
hommes mais je pense au lieu de penser à
les vivre alors dans les cieux cherche
maintenant à fait descendre à le ciel
sur la terre qu'est ce que je veux dire
je découvre que la paix est d'essence
divine
l'afer est spirituelle la paix si elle
peut se connaître lors de notre que l'a
fait de se partager la paix se donner
car on dit la plus belle femme au monde
ne peut donner que ce qu'elle a qu'est
ce que tu as été un agent de paix at il
reçu la paix si oui je vais la donner à
quelqu'un et je pense oui
quand je suis allé à les y est j'y vais
chaque année depuis plus de 15 ans
maintenant
quand tu vois quelqu'un on dit quoi
chaleur shalom on répond la paix en dans
la paix et si nous pouvons être
l'artisan qui donne la paix qui
ponctuent la paix je crois que la
primera oui
d'autres ont pensé que les agents qui
sèment le trouble sur le prenait à les
enfermer dans un lieu oui nous avons des
prisons mais j'ai découvert que les
présentes n'ont jamais été des lieux de
transformation de vie mais les prisons
ont plutôt à mêler maintenant les gens à
se dégrader
les petits gangsters en somme en tant
que des grands danseurs et je crois que
le monde envoie échoué en mettant alors
ces personnes dans les endroits où on
vire renforcer encore les dégâts dans
leur vie devenir des kamikazes passé ont
reçu plus d'un coup mais je crois et je
pense de tout mon coeur que la paix la
bêta paix est impossible
mais comment si le mot ou d'une autre
coeur car la paix vu habile en hauteur
et cette paix qui peut la recevoir de la
daisy l'obtenir la répondre tout de toi
et le monde sur un monde meilleur
je crois que cela est possible si tu pas
la condition d'être un agent de paix
peace mais que je le veux et toi si oui
nous pouvons à le bâtir un monde
meilleur nous bâtir un monde meilleur ou
pour le pire la peur de nous et la paix
régnera dans la nation et pour finir je
dirais ceci tu peux être aussi un havre
de paix j'ai découvert par expérience
qu'il ya des personnes qui sont capables
le pôle a fait autour d'elle j'ai
découvert ce sont les femmes
oui vous les femmes vous êtes alors
vraiment une pièce précieuse
les femmes elles sont très émotive les
femmes sont très intuitive les femmes
voir plus loin que les hommes les femmes
qui je parlais pas mais celle que les
douleurs de l'enfantement celles là sont
capables aujourd'hui de dix noms on peut
mieux faire
ces femmes ne sont pas comme les hommes
qui sèment le trouble mais pense à allah
de l'abattement elle permet de répandre
la paix j'y crois si nous avons des
femmes élevées alors indien de la
société occupe des postes de décision
les femmes pourront changer de monde et
on aura un monde paisible
je crois que c'est possible et cela va
se passer
soit maintenant un havre de paix comme
moi soit dix ans de paix
[Applaudissements]